>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Gail Shirazi: Hi,
I'm Gail Shirazi
of the Israel-Judaic Section
here at the Library of Congress.
Welcome to our program
today, Reading Claudius,
a book and author talk
by Caroline Heller.
This event is being cosponsored
by the European Division,
the Hebrew Language Table
at the Library of Congress,
in cooperation with
the Czech Embassy.
I would like to thank Grant
Harris and the European Division,
Audrey Fisher in the
Public Affairs Office,
Galena Teverovski [assumed spelling]
and Heim Golchek [assumed spelling]
of the IJ section at the library,
and Mary Fetzko at the Embassy
of the Czech Republic, and I'd
like to thank Mary Bisbee-Beek
Caroline's publisher, and of course,
our speaker, Caroline Heller.
Dr. Heller is Director of the
Interdisciplinary PhD Program
in Educational Studies
at Lesley University.
She's also a professor the in
the Graduate School of Education.
Dr. Heller, has a BA from
the University of Chicago,
an MFA from Bennington College,
and a doctorate in education
from the University of
California at Berkeley.
One of her areas of interest is
the connection of reading, writing,
and storytellling to selfhood,
particularly for refugee
populations.
Reading Claudius presents a
vivid and, for me, visual picture
of refugee life in Europe,
particularly Prague,
nd then following it to the Americas
where her family came as refugees.
When I read her book, I felt like
I was sitting, as I told Caroline,
right in the café
next to these people.
It let me enter the book,
and that happens so rarely
with Holocaust literature.
Usually you're reading somebody
else's, but this really,
thank you Caroline, for
making it so vivid and alive.
So I would like to thank Caroline
again, and the floor's all yours.
[ Applause ]
>> Caroline Heller: I
have no announcements.
So thank you so much
for coming, and Gail,
thank you for making this happen,
and of all the many sponsors.
I particularly want to thank
Czech Embassy, and you will find
out very shortly, if you
haven't read Reading Claudius,
what that country meant
to both my parents.
It is crazy-wonderful to be
reading at the Library of Congress.
It is unbelievable really,
and there are people
in the audience I haven't
seen in a long time,
and I want to particularly
acknowledge Jody Bernstein,
who was my mother's -- you get to
know my mother in a moment, but she,
Jody, was my mother's most
beloved American friend,
and Jody that you're here means
that my dad and mom are here.
>> Thank you.
>> Caroline Heller: And I don't
think it's a spoiler alert
to tell you that Washington DC
is a bit character in the book,
because my brother and
I were both born here
at George Washington Hospital and
my father's first medical job was
at Group Health in Washington
DC, which was really the first,
you know, quasi-socialist,
as some people like to say,
medical world in this country.
So I just want to make a few remarks
about publishing one's
first major book
when one is a little older, as I am.
It's a period of incredible
joy and a sense of plentitude.
That of all the people in the world
who have important stories to tell,
yours gets published and is found in
a beautiful cover and has a Library
of Congress ISBN number and
all of those wonderful things,
but in addition, it was strangely
discombobulating, writing
and researching this
book for so long.
Most people know that that
can be a very lonely time,
but I was unprepared for the fact
that really publishing a book
is quite lonely, as well,
in that you're alone with this
baby, whom you care so much about,
and it's it and you, and then
suddenly, this beloved organism is
in the world, and you don't know
who it's with, and you don't know
if it's cared for properly
and loved, and so occasions
like this are -- really help a
great deal in that particular sense
of loneliness, because you're with
the people who have read the book
or will read the book and all
of that is really eased
in one's heart and soul.
So all of which is to say
thank you again for coming.
Well, my hope for writing
Reading Claudius, it is both small
and contained to share a
very personal family story.
A kind of an elegy, a love letter
to my parents, but it's also big
and expansive in its own way to
inspire readers of Reading Claudius
to really think about how thought
and history have over all lives
in ways that we often don't
fully understand or recognize,
and most particularly, for those
of us whose parents or grandparents
or great-grandparents have
experienced enormous political
upheavals and dislocations
and sometimes threatening
to destroy them, as
in my parents' case,
and after which must somehow
re-create their coherence,
their sense of themselves and
their sense of the future,
and in the writing of Reading
Claudius, I also recognize so fully
that they must've, as Gail alluded,
to the next generation and refugees
in America, they must also figure
out how to imagine a future
for their children in a land
that they never anticipated raising
their children in because the land
that they did think would always
be theirs no longer existed.
So I recognize that and
adored my parents all
over again with that recognition.
In my own family's case,
the political trauma,
the historical crisis
was World War II,
and what was destroyed was my
parents beloved Central Europe,
Prague, in their lives at the heart
of that sense of Central Europe.
So Reading Claudius,
as Gail mentioned,
is very much about that
former world, that lost world,
very much taking places in
the cafés, the coffee houses
that Gail alluded to, where in
that place and during that time,
the sense of the political and
the intellectual and the creative
and the artistic and the literary
were all somehow one in the same,
and I think many of us long for that
kind of spirit in the United States,
and in the coffee houses that my
parents and uncles frequented,
it was always, there were day-long
and week-long, month-long debates,
always to the intermingling
with the smell of coffee
and the abundant cigarette smoke,
and I'm glad that Gail
mentioned how visual that was,
because I felt I was there, too.
Reading Claudius is
also about memory.
I had a kind of an epiphany
about that, about the story being
about memory, when my spouse
and I saw the Laurie Anderson
play Homeland some years ago,
just when I was in the throes
of finishing Reading Claudius,
and the play opens with birds in the
sky, and it's before there is land.
It's before land exists, and the
father and the mother bird die,
and because there's no land,
there's no place to bury them,
and so Laurie Anderson says,
"The daughter bird buries them
in the back of her head."
And she says that "This is
the beginning of memory,"
and I was just floored by
that because I realized
in writing the book that
I and probably many of us,
perhaps most of us, bury our
parents in the backs of our heads.
So Reading Claudius is about that,
and it's about how
all those memories
and meanings get communicated and
bequeathed to the next generation
and all that gets lost
along the way,
and in my case, that
was a great deal.
So before I introduce the key
players and read a little bit,
many people ask me, "Why
are you writing a book
about the Emperor Claudius when this
book supposedly is about Prague?"
and I just want to clue you
in that it's not the Emperor.
Claudius in the title
refers to Matthias Claudius,
and old German poet,
an 18th century poet,
who many Central European
children were weaned on.
Everyone read Claudius's poems.
They're very simple
and quite beautiful,
and I witnessed both
my mother and father
in the weeks before they died going
back to a little book of his poems
that my mother managed to
get out of Europe and read
to each other Claudius' poems, and
that's what inspired the title,
which my editor, for a long
time, wanted to change,
because she thought everyone
will be looking for the emperor,
and then in the end
Reading Claudius,
it had been Reading Claudius
for so long that she just,
she and I both said it's got
to stay Reading Claudius.
So that's how the title came to be.
Well, Reading Claudius has
three starring players.
In part two of the book, my brother
and I become bit stars, as well,
but the three starring players
are my mother Leise Florsheim,
who came to Prague from
Frankfurt, Germany, in 1933,
just because Hitler
became Chancellor,
because she was no longer allowed to
go onto higher education in Germany,
and in Prague, she met a
fellow medical student,
who would later become
my father Paul Heller,
but while this fellow Paul Heller
developed a very quiet, shy,
but very big on Leise, Leise gave
her heart to Paul's older brother,
Erich, who was already
kind of a literary figure
and philosophy figure among the
young Jewish students in Prague.
He was an aspiring writer
already doing some publishing
and also the head of the
Socialist Student Movement.
So Erich became quite
prominent on the Nazi's radar,
and thus began a combustible
romantic triangle
that would last a lifetime and
show itself in various ways,
and that forms the core of the
personal story of Reading Claudius,
and the war itself, of course,
is the air that surrounds
that triangle.
In late summer of 1938,
when the growing power
of the Nazis made it very dangerous
for German Jews to remain in Europe
at all, my mother got out and
made it to the United States.
Some months later, my
uncle, who as I mentioned,
was quite a prominent
anti-Nazi, fled illegally
across the Polish border and made
it to safety in Cambridge, England,
but a short time after that, and
it was really just a matter of days
after Paul's graduation from
medical school, war broke out,
and Paul was arrested in
the middle of the night
in the first public round up
in Prague and transported first
to Dachau then to Buchenwald,
with a year spent in Auschwitz
and then back to Buchenwald, and
all in all, remaining in the camps
for 6 years until they
were liberated in 1945.
In doing research for the book,
I made many trips to Europe,
and in one of those,
I interviewed one
of the remaining surviving friends
of my parents' European friends,
and she told me in great detail
about the Sunday afternoon when she
and my uncle and everyone listening
to the radio that night found
out that my father had survived, and
so I want to play a short broadcast
that was part of a postscript for
the Sunday BBC News this evening
that no one in the group that was
with Eve Adler Road [assumed
spelling] knew that this was
to be aired that evening.
They didn't yet know
that Paul had survived.
>> April 15, 1945.
>> Permit me to tell you
what you would have seen
and heard had you had
been with me on Thursday.
It will not be pleasant listening.
If you are at lunch, or
if you have no appetite
to hear what Germans have
done, now is a good time
to switch off the radio for I
propose to tell you of Buchenwald.
It is on a small hill about four
miles outside Weimar, and it was one
of the largest concentration
camps in Germany,
and it was built to last.
As we approached it, we saw about
a hundred men in civilian clothes
with rifles advancing in
open-order across the field.
There were a few shots.
We stopped to inquire.
We're told that some of
the prisoners had a couple
of SS men cornered in there.
We drove on, reached the main gate.
The prisoners crowed
up behind the wire.
We entered.
And now, let me tell
this in the first-person,
for I was the least important
person there, as you can hear.
There surged around me
an evil-smelling stink.
Men and boys reached
out to touch me.
They were in rags and
the remnants of uniforms.
Death had already had
marked many of them,
but they were smiling
with their eyes.
I looked out over that mass of
men to the green fields beyond,
where well-fed Germans
were ploughing.
A German, Fritz Kersheimer,
came up and said,
"May I show you around the camp?
I've been here for ten years."
An Englishman stood to attention
saying, "May I introduce myself?
Delighted to see you.
And can you tell me when some
of our folks will be along?"
I told him, "Soon," and asked
to see one of the barracks.
It happened to be occupied
by Czechoslovakians.
When I entered, men crowded around,
tried to lift me to their shoulders.
They were too weak.
Many of them could
not get out of bed.
I was told that this building
had once stabled 80 horses.
There were 1200 men
in it, five to a bunk.
The stink was beyond
all description.
When I reached the center of the
barracks, a man came up and said,
"You remember me, I am Patr
Zenkl, one time mayor of Prague."
I remembered him, but
did not recognize him.
He asked about Benes
and Jan Masaryk.
I asked how many men had died in
that building during the last month.
They called the doctor;
we inspected his records.
There were only names in the
little black book, nothing more --
nothing of who had been where,
what they had done or hoped.
Behind the names of those who
had died there was a cross.
I counted them.
They totaled 242; 242
out of 1200 in one month.
As I walked down to the end of
the barracks, there was applause
from the men too weak
to get out of bed.
It sounded like the hand-clapping
of babies, they were so weak.
The doctor's name was Paul Heller.
He had been there since '38.
>> Caroline Heller: Well I just
want to read a couple of sections,
short sections from the part
one and one from part two,
and then I hope very much
to engage in conversation
and invite you to ask questions.
This first section takes
place in part one of the book,
and it takes place right after
the infamous Munich Agreement,
which most of you know ceded the
Northwest part of Czechoslovakia
to Hitler in order to
appease his thirst for power.
Czechoslovakia was quite weakened
by the death of its first president,
and Hitler took that as a moment
to set his sights on new conquests,
and this was all done
without the permission
of the new Czech President.
It was a deal that was
negotiated by Neville Chamberlain,
and people who lived, Jews
and anti-Nazis who lived
in the Northwest section of
Prague had to get out immediately,
because it would be
Nazified within 24 hours.
So my father, who had just
taken a day-long series
of medical examinations
and didn't know that all
of this was happening while he was
taking his exams, stoked himself
on coffee and rented a cab and
went to the Northwest section
of Czechoslovakia to bring his
mother and his and to safety,
which was presumed to be still a
safe destination to come to Prague,
and my father grew up in that
Northwest section of Czechoslovakia.
When Paul arrived at 16
Welmuhlstrasse just before midnight,
the curtains of the Heller
family apartment were drawn.
Else Heller was seated on the
sofa in the front sitting room,
which was lit by candles.
There were rumors of bombings, she
told Paul, and she'd been advised
to turn off all the electricity.
She was dressed formally, her long
hair still jet black at 54 gathered
in a bun at the back of her neck.
In front of her, the marble-top
coffee table was piled with books,
clothes, and open boxes of
photographs and letters.
On the floor next to her sat
her suitcase and handbag.
She was clutching a small paper bowl
laminated with pictures of sea birds
that Erich had made for
her when he was a boy.
"You have to put candy in it in
order for it to be balanced,"
she said as she looked up at Paul.
Her face ashen.
"Kind of like me," Paul said, trying
to bring lightness to his voice
to avoid frightening
his mother any further.
"I must tell you that
cousin Fanny had yesterday,
out of the blue, a
tonsils operation."
she went on, making
conversation, as she always did
when she was nervous and upset.
Lana and Carl came by and told
me she was in the hospital.
"The cab is waiting.
Mother, we must go."
"Do you remember when Erich cut
his finger making this bowl?"
she asked, running her hand
across its bumpy, varnished edge.
"He made a frightful fuss,
a most terrible fuss.
Do you remember that?"
Else's eyes were cavernous.
"Mother, you'll feel better
once you're in the cab."
"You must let me decide how
I feel," she said sharply.
"I didn't have time
to withdraw money.
I haven't selected what I must take.
I haven't sorted through
father's books.
I cannot go.
Perhaps tomorrow."
She sat stiff and delicate,
her coat draped over her lap.
"Mother, we can do that from Prague.
Anny can help us.
She can send things.
Else's eyes roamed over the room,
turning to the open
boxes on the table.
She fingered Erich's
paper bowl again.
"Have you eaten?"
Paul nodded.
"But you'll have a bite
of something with me, no?"
"We haven't the time, mother.
We'll eat at Mina's."
He stood motionless in front of her
for several moments then
moved toward where she sat.
"Mother, we must leave.
We must go now.
Please let me help you."
He spoke in a stern and unequivocal
he'd never used with her.
He felt the blood go to
the back of his neck.
Else Heller was a tiny
woman, standing under 5 feet,
but over that height,
she was solidly built.
Paul put his had over her
forearm, but she rose on her own,
went down the hall to the kitchen,
and came back carrying
the silver butter mold
that Alfred's parents had
given them at their wedding.
She added it, along with the
bowl, to one of the boxes,
applied a few drops of cologne
from a bottle in her handbag,
and stooped to blow out the candles.
Without looking at Paul, she laced
her arm in his and let him lead her
down the steps and out the door
into the drizzly open night.
The street, which rarely
saw traffic,
was filled with cars and taxicabs.
The route to Ida's
apartment took them past Paul
and Erich's gymnasium, and
the candle-lit apartment
where the parents of Paul's
childhood friend, Camillo Fleischer,
the only other Jewish boy in
his gymnasium class, lived.
He wondered what Camillo and
his family were planning to do.
The taxi climbed the hill
past the Komatau Kino
and the music hall were Paul
and Erich had taken part
in the children's theater,
and Dr. Fleishman had
conducted the Komatau Orchestra
and continued past Bobby Komisch's
haberdashery, Mendel's Bookstore,
then across the railroad bridge
and past the old iron ore quarry.
All until that night,
the unquestioned constants
in Paul's life.
Tante Ida was waiting in the
alcove doorway of her building,
a small suitcase by her side.
She was dressed warmly.
The the tight-laced
collar she always wore
to Saturday services
visible under her jacket.
"Du Bist so tuchtig, Pauli."
the diminutive 68-year-old
said in the authoritative tone
in which she issued
all her judgments.
It was the highest accolade one
could receive from Tante Ida.
Levelheaded, able to
get things done.
Paul put her bag next to his
mother's on the front seat.
The two women sat in back
on either side of Paul
in their rain-moist fur jackets,
their small spectacles glinting
in all directions as the cab
followed traffic toward the main
road for what was usually a
two hour ride back to Prague
but likely would take
far longer tonight.
The windows were open just
enough to let the smells
of exhaust and wet pavement in.
The honking and screeching
of brakes in the middle
of the night had a surreal quality.
Else loosened the laces
on her shoes.
Through the rear-view
mirror, Paul could see
in the distance the dim lights of
other [inaudible] towns nestled
at the foot of the mountains.
No one exhaled a normal breath.
The only words came from the taxi
driver, who talked about God.
That day he'd become
convinced for an absolute fact
that there was none, he said.
In the silence, he made
weak, worried jokes.
"How can anyone take
the Nazis seriously?
They march too much."
Just before dawn, as
the rain was ending,
they arrived at Walter
and Mina's apartment.
Grandma Mina, whose sense of humor
was legendary, poured hot coffee
from a silver earn the
sputtered more than flowed.
"My ribald friends
regard this coffee pot
as having prostate trouble.
It has a problem.
It has a problem."
she declared with a
great heave of a laugh,
pretending like the taxi driver and
like Paul to a sense of normalcy
that she surely did not feel.
She poured thick, pulpy
orange juice, which Paul,
awakening to his body for the
first time since he'd walked
out of the examination
hall over 15 hours before,
drank with such voraciousness,
that it dribbled over his chin.
As the sun came up, Mina enlisted
Else and Ida's advice on the cooking
of eggs for their breakfast
and a debate, led by Tante Ida,
about the best way
to fry them followed.
That night, instead of returning
to his dormitory, Paul collapsed
on the sofa in the room that his
mother and aunt now occupied,
listening to their short,
shallow breaths as they slept.
The world, which for so long
in his mind had looked one way,
had begun to look totally different.
Well, I want to take you from
Prague to Riverside, Illinois,
which is jarring, believe me.
[laughter] This is a
section from part two.
Part two was called the Unthought
Known, which implies the degree
to which children know
what they don't know.
They absorb something that
they don't realize they know,
and this little section
is called The Brick,
and it is about that moment when I
knew something I didn't know I knew.
I became a shark in
the summer of 1957,
just months after I'd been sick.
I had encephalitis when I was
a little girl and it came right
after this, or I was
sick right before this.
I'd begun that summer as
a minnow, and then along
with another 7-year-old girl,
having made the most progress
in the Riverside Summer
Swimming Program,
was promoted to the rank of shark.
I walked through the
corridor of mandatory showers,
my bare feet slapping the puddles
gathering on the tiles and stood
for a moment in the arched entrance
to the pool where the still water
and the clean, cold
air felt otherworldly.
Today, the last day of the
summer season, my mother would be
in the bleachers watching me.
After the minnows, fish, and
flying fish performed their kicks
and strokes, wrapped themselves in
towels, and joined their families
in the bleachers, the sharks lined
up along the deep end and dived in,
swimming two lengths of the pool
in the hushed peacefulness
of the water.
The feel and sound of my sturdy,
rhythmic strokes filled me with joy.
At the end of our laps, the
athletic director, Mr. Perkins,
his sports medallion shimmering
in his dark chest hair,
grabbed the microphone he
used for just to this day
and announced my name and that
of the other little girl whose
swimming had most improved.
He knelt down between
us as he explained.
The words amplified through
his microphone that both
of us would dive into the deep end
and whoever retrieved the 3-pound
rubber brick from the bottom
of the pool would be the 1957 summer
champion and receive a trophy.
After that moment, I have no
memory of the other little girl.
I dived in, the cold water seeping
on the edge of my bathing cap
as my arms and hands pulled my body
down toward the shed
we dark object below.
I took firm hold of the brick in my
left hand, allowing my stronger arm
and hand to power me to the
surface of the pool and my triumph.
Mr. Perkins pulled me from the water
and held up the black rubber brick
to the audience as the
emblem of my victory.
To a loud current of applause
coming from the bleachers,
he then presented me with a trophy.
A small golden girl with a tiny face
of barely discernible
features standing
on a vanilla-white
pedestal poised to dive.
My pride was so great
it was almost painful.
Scrunching my eyes against the
light coming through the windows
above the bleachers, I
found my mother's face.
She was glancing right, then
left, as if seeking confirmation
from the mothers sitting around her
that this great event
had really happened.
When she looked toward me,
her face was awash in tears.
Even as in a separate corner
of my mind I replayed
every thrilling stroke
that have propelled me from
the bottom of the pool, now,
seeing my mother's face,
I could scarcely breathe.
Her tears seemed earthshaking,
as if my performance had
represented the clear condition
of everything she needed.
Before my dive, I hadn't known
that I possessed the strength
that had won me this
prize, and now in a flash,
I felt my own realization taken
from me, engulfed by the intensity
of my mother's emotion before
I could claim it as my own.
Trying to hold myself tall,
to step back into the exultation
I'd felt a moment before,
I smiled at her, but
what I'd felt was gone.
Replacing my pride
came in anguish deeper
than anything I had words for.
Achingly devoted to her, I did
not have it in my power to think,
much less to say, "I'm
not really the strong.
I will not always be
able to do this.
I will disappoint you."
It was the first time I
remember wanting to go backward
into tininess, into invisibility.
On the drive home, my thighs damp
against the hot vinyl car seat,
my trophy lying on the seat
between my mother and me,
the responsibility I
felt to make her happy,
to make both my parents proud,
was too great for my body to hold.
I started to cry so hard
that my nose began to bleed.
Well, I know it's kind of hard
to come back from being in Prague
and in the high school swimming
pool with me to asking questions
and conversation, but I really
enjoy that part of this.
So please do feel free
to comment or question.
Gail?
>> Gail Shirazi: You have to
first of all repeat the question
for the webcast, but my
question is how did --
did they talk about it at all?
In the book, you talk about
some of your research.
Could you talk about how they
talked about the experiences
and how you filled
in the rest of it?
>> Caroline Heller: Yes.
>> Gail Shirazi: Repeat
the question.
>> Caroline Heller:
Gail asked how I --
how my parents talked about the past
and how I filled in the rest of it.
They didn't.
As Jody knows, we grew
up, my brother and I grew
up in a very Christian Republican
suburban, and my parents,
like so many refugees, particularly
of that time in certainly now,
as well, were trying to
figure out how to assimilate,
and the whole idea of a melting
pot, although I don't think
that was the term in the
50s, was very appealing,
and they somehow felt they
really didn't need to talk
about being Jewish or
to talk about the past,
and that was the way to go forward.
So they talked very rarely
what my brother and I knew
or what we were told was that
my father had been a prisoner,
and the implication was
that he'd been a soldier,
and we just knew not
to ask questions.
We were told that our
grandparents, both our grandfathers,
had died of heart attacks, and we
were -- things were coated over.
Tom, my brother and I, never
really knew if this was just sort
of a developing habit,
you know, that my parents,
just little by little things
didn't get talked about
or whether it was a deeply conscious
decision to never talk about it,
but that is how we were raised
until a moment in the book
when my brother had already
gone to college and I was
in my later years of high school.
One of my classmates
is here from Riverside.
Things started to come out.
There was a moment in
a high school class
when my teacher asked is there
anyone in the class who's Jewish,
because someone, some classmate
whom I was actually very fond of,
had made a virulent anti-somatic
remark, and I felt my blood boil,
and I was a very shy, quiet
kid, and I just wanted
to read him the riot act, and
we kind of started sparring,
and my American history teacher
stopped it and said, "I need to know
if there's anyone in the
class who is Jewish."
and I had a total out
of body experience,
in part because I was frightened,
and in part because I realized I
somehow didn't know the answer,
but again, it was sort
of in unthought known
that I did know the answer to.
So that was a pivotal
moment, as I remember it.
Ironically, I don't remember what
happened after that, if I went home
and said to my parents, you
know, "What's going on here?"
Funny how the mind works.
When they got older, as Jody knows,
more and more came out to the point
where a lot came out, and I was
lucky enough to have my father well
into his old age, and
everything started to pour out,
this whole scene with my
grandmother and my great aunt.
He said he would have such a hunger
to talk about it that he would come
out again after he talked about it.
He said, "I remember my
mother untied her shoes.
I don't know why she
untied her shoes."
and what the cab driver said, and my
mother, who died of a brain tumor,
and we knew it was
a terminal illness,
I taped her stories before she died,
and I have about 12 audio tapes,
but Gail, much of the early
story, I have to imagine.
I did an enormous amount of research
and have everything kind of down
about what happened, but of
course, what you said about feeling
like you are in the coffeehouse
is one has to add dialogue.
One has to do a bit of imagining
to bring all the textures
in to make it a story,
and I did some of that.
Although so many of the details
were from my mother and father
and from someone's
here, Susie Cowan-Evans,
who knew my uncle very well.
He has an archive at
Northwestern University.
So there were many
archival records, as well.
>> Gail Shirazi: What did
you do with those tapes?
Did you copy them and give
them to the Holocaust Museum?
>> Caroline Heller: No, I'm slowly
becoming willing to give things up.
I've given a lot of things
to my brother's children,
and I will do that.
That's an excellent suggestion.
Other comments and -- yes, sir?
>> How did you get started
in writing the book?
What was the inspiration
to put it into a book form?
>> Caroline Heller: This gentlemen
asked what was the inspiration
to put it in book form.
Well --
>> Gail Shirazi: I'm just going to
identify who's raising their hand.
>> Caroline Heller: Got it.
Yes. There was a pivotal scene when
my mother was dying where my uncle,
and I'd never really -- I knew.
My mother told me when I was
a teenager, late in my teens
that Erich had been her
sweetheart before my father was,
but I had never seen sparks
between my mother and my uncle.
I more felt combustion.
You know, not that kind of spark,
but more like anger almost,
that kind of energy, but when
my mother was dying, Erich,
who lived in Evanston, my mother
died at Evanston Hospital,
came to her room almost
every day and read to her
from the Claudius book, and that
was a moment when I thought,
where I really registered, there
was this life that was kind
of the real life, and
I wasn't there,
and I registered their relationship,
and I think that I thought
that I need to one
day write their story.
Then I went, and one of my
upper-class people, I went,
I always loved to write,
and I really wanted
to develop my writing
chops, and I went to an MFA.
I got a grant to do some research,
and I used the money to get an MFA
at Bennington, and at
Bennington, I've met Sven Birkerts,
a very fine literary critic,
who was my first teacher there,
and I didn't know who he was, and
so I went to the Bennington Library
because I thought I should
brush up on my teachers,
and what do I find the book
that contains, by Sven,
that contains an essay
about Erich Heller.
So I had an enormous
transference with Sven.
I could barely speak with him
for the first week at Bennington,
but he was a great admirer
of Erich, of Erich's work,
and he basically said, "You've
got to write this story."
and that's when I really
started in on it.
>> I don't know how to
articulate this, but in the book,
the letters that were written at the
same time from Erich to your mother
and from Paul really showed
the characters so completely
of the two different men, and I
wondered how you felt about that
when you got privy to that,
because I felt that Erich was
so superficial, even though he
was brilliant, and here's Paul,
suffering and trying to survive.
I was very moved by those
letters, and I wondered,
could letters be sent out of
these concentration camps?
How did they arrive?
>> Gail Shirazi: Repeat
the question.
>> Caroline Heller: Phyllis?
>> Phyllis.
>> Caroline Heller: Phyllis
asked about the sort of central,
one of the center chapters
in the book that's pretty
much all letters juxtaposed,
my uncle's letters to his
amour, who was a soldier
and my father's diary entries,
and how I came upon those letters.
First my -- let me say first
that that was an incredibly
difficult chapter to write
because number one, I didn't feel
as the next generation and I think
so many people feel that way,
what right do I have
to write about the war?
I felt like I could manage
to write about before the war
and after the war, but
the war is so not mine,
and who on Earth is able
to write well about it?
I also had, from being
my parents' daughter
and not my uncle's daughter.
So I had, you know, I was very close
to my uncle in certain ways but not
in the ways I was to my parents,
and I didn't admire him as much
as many people did because of what
I found out, and because of that,
I don't know if I would call
it superficiality, Phyllis,
although that's an interesting term.
I would more kind of
a above it all(ness).
Maybe that is what
superficiality is.
He doesn't sort of need to
be like all the rest of us.
So I was trying.
Of course, when one writes a book,
one has to be fair to everybody.
It's not interesting to write a book
about the difficulty
Caroline has with her uncle.
So I decided I needed
to just let my --
let the documentation of those
years come from the people.
Those letters from my
uncle to Graham Story,
who was his first boyfriend,
spoiler alert [laughter],
are in the archive at Northwestern.
Why the letters from my uncle to
Graham are there, I don't know,
because one would think Graham's
letters to my uncle would be there.
I think I don't know
why they are there.
I think in their breakup Graham must
have sent my uncle all the letters.
I don't know, but I used
excerpts from those letters.
My father was on a death march, as
those of you who read the book know,
from Auschwitz back to Buchenwald,
when the Nazis had the delusion
that they could cover their tracks
and have these horrifying
death marches, and that somehow
that would mask what was going
on in the concentration camps,
and my father obviously
survived that death march,
but he didn't anticipate that
he would and with great reason.
So toward the end of
the death march,
as the prisoners were being
herded into a barn, my father laid
down under a farmer's calendar with
a pencil tied to it on the wall,
and he thought at that moment,
"They're going to kill me anyway.
I am going to stuff this
in my pocket and write."
and he did.
I have that calendar, and my
father wrote those notes down,
and after Reading Claudius came out,
I got an email from a young woman.
Well, my age, very young
woman, in Portland who said,
"You're the daughter of Paul Heller.
My father (Mary's father) was
the chaplain," the Army chaplain
in Bayreuth which is one the --
which is the the first place my
father kind of stayed for any length
of time as he was getting
out of Europe,
and that chaplain had a very lovely
person who was working with him,
and she offered to, you know,
write up, sit with my dad,
and write up those notes,
and I didn't know about that.
Mary told me the genesis
of how they became clearer.
Then he translated them and
actually published that diary
in Midstream Magazine in mid 80s.
>> I mean, it's the kind
of thing that you could say
that you could only read in a book.
When you mentioned the pencil
hanging and the calendar.
You know, I felt it
too, as Gail does.
I thought, "My God, how he
disappeared is like just a miracle
that he could do that
and that he kept his wits
and wrote all of that."
>> Caroline Heller: Yeah, yeah,
yeah, he was not the easiest dad,
as some people in the room know,
but he was an extraordinary --
I mean, of all the
survivors I've met, I can't --
my father was really
quite a healthy,
healthy emotionally in so many ways.
I mean, in some ways, he wasn't.
Of course, that experience damaged
him, but he was extraordinary.
>> He was.
Very rational and passionate
at the same time.
I love that [inaudible].
>> Caroline Heller: Yes, Marcia.
>> First, congratulations
on the book.
>> Caroline Heller: Thank you.
>> And second it's so
intensely personal.
I'm wondering whether
there were times
when you found it very difficult
to continue writing it, and if so,
how did you overcome
that and just keep going?
In addition to Sven's encouragement
and also the memories
of your parents.
>> Caroline Heller: I wrote
an essay about my father.
It's now -- a version of it is
now the last chapter of the book.
It's called Opti-Lens, when he
was kind of getting diminished,
in part because he was losing his
sight, and my stepmother had gone
on a trip, and so I was alone with
my father, sort of tending to him
for a couple of weeks, and he
was driving me absolutely crazy,
and so I wrote little notes about
his experience trying to learn how
to use a reading machine that would
help him to see, and at Bennington,
I was encouraged to really work that
piece because it was quite good,
and when my father
was on his deathbed,
my older brother said,
"Read him that piece."
And I thought, "Absolutely not."
It's the sort of warts and all.
I don't want this to
be my parting gift,
but I always do what my
brother tells me to do.
So I did, and in the middle of
it, I thought, "This is awful."
because my father had no expression,
but I sort of couldn't stop.
I was in it, and toward the end he
got a little just mischievous grin
that Jody knows so well,
and said, "Caroline,
you should submit this somewhere."
[ Laughter ]
And I did after he died, and it
was published, and an agent read it
and contacted me, and I got
a contract within a few days
from Random House,
crazy good fortune.
So I had to write the book,
but that certainly doesn't mean
that it was in any way easy.
I alluded to it with Phyllis's
question about how difficult
that center portion was, and
the whole thing, you know,
the center portion, when I read
my father's death march diary,
and I had read it many times,
it was as though someone were,
for the first time, telling
me this is what your dad --
it was as though I never
knew anything about it,
the degree to which it absolutely
undid me, what he went through,
and I just -- I thought there
was something wrong with me
that I would be, you know, be
willing to go into that darkness,
but it was also so
compelling to do so.
So it was very hard.
It was very hard to
write about myself.
This is something.
Part two is all the
idea of my editor.
I thought I was done about five
years, four years before I was done
because it's like here's the
story of my parents, and no.
You have to be in it.
I think it makes it
a much better book,
but I never anticipated
telling my story.
I never anticipated
coming out to the world.
It's just the things one does
that the sort of the momentum
of the words just suddenly you're
in a position where you have
to do something that you
didn't anticipate doing
because the story matters
suddenly so much to you.
>> Thank you.
>> Caroline Heller: Anything else?
>> I have one.
Did your parents ever
visit Czechoslovakia?
>> Caroline Heller: Yes, they
did, and I was with them.
It was in 1982.
It was still under communist
rule, and it was very emotional.
My father crazily was detained in
the airport because in that myopia
of the new regime, the
communist regime basically,
Hitler never happened.
It was never -- and he, according
to the police, the airport police,
they had no reasonable record of
why my father left Czechoslovakia,
and he was so pale when
he came out of that room.
It was so difficult, so strange, but
that was the worst part of the trip.
Then it was just incredible
to be with my parents,
and my mother took me
to the coffeehouses.
Many of them are gone.
Some aren't, and to be able to do
that with my parents
was just amazing,
and my mother got sick
shortly thereafter.
So it was such a gift.
>> The house survived?
They visit that place
where used to live?
>> Caroline Heller: My
father visited his house,
and there was still his apartment.
There was still a little -- you
could see the imprint of the plaque
that had said -- his Dr.
Alfred Heller, and it was --
>> Wow.
>> Gail Shirazi: Well, I'd
like to thank you for coming.
>> Caroline Heller:
Thank you so much.
[ Applause ]
>> Gail Shirazi: And if anybody
wants to buy copies of the book,
they're being sold outside,
and Caroline, I'm sure,
would love to sign them,
and it's really a treat
to have an author come
and talk about her book,
and it was a wonderful book.
Thank you.
Thank you for writing it.
[ Applause ]
>> This is been a presentation
of Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.